hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
[Music]
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find if they grow up to be classy
or if there's the big old piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
glorious day we're down here at aunt
tony's basement
feeling fine feeling good my co-host is
coming at you
from right next to me he is the ceo of
ru garbage he's getting into nfts and
bitcoin
kid's got his toe in a lot of pools it's
got cash these days
i call them mr ryan but give it up for
kippy kevin james
everybody hey gang what's up thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube
subscribe there and as you know those
numbers are true to roof through the
[ __ ] room okay
through the roof patreon.com you can
sign up you get bonus episodes at ayg
that don't get released to the public
not a lot of people
picked up on that there's we we do
weekly episodes that don't go out you
can
only get them on patreon we get do
episodes of hard feelings and then live
streams
on patreon as well also we just dropped
the kippy mtv cribs edition
on patreon that's up go check that we
got a lot of [ __ ] business today fun
times
the cards are still some cards left you
can get link will be in the description
they went quick there's not that many i
don't even know if they're by the time
you hear this they might be gone
uh and then also the live shows will be
in raleigh north carolina
uh on 420 and then 421 will be in
nashville get those [ __ ] tickets
don't make us look like [ __ ] yeah no
[ __ ] we got the guys from the coast
calling every day
up our asses let's move some [ __ ]
merchandise here it's the coast of
delaware but still we're trying
i got the guys from rehoboth all over me
gang real quick give us a nice shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man the [ __ ] genius behind the
kippy's castle
video give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby
mcmullen what up what up t-bone dude
chilling stressful day getting [ __ ] by
instagram with their goddamn copyright
[ __ ] we got
we had toby hemmed up early on this
morning i was like you [ __ ] idiot you
didn't use royalty-free music
i did it was youtube i'm on the phone
with nashville [ __ ] talking about
copyright infringement it's [ __ ]
crazy it's my buddy's band man they said
it was cool
they said it was cool man sorry you
don't know bob seeger
that's why you don't do business with
friends dawg gang this is a [ __ ]
family episode an old school one old
school one
jump street
[Laughter]
all the way back to the streets of the
east village running around
the lower east side whatever i don't
know what you're talking about gang we
couldn't be more excited ever incredibly
special guest back with us today if you
haven't checked out his episode make
sure you check it out
we're gonna do some patreon questions
some facebook questions
we're here answering your [ __ ]
questions give it up you better save
something
as soon as i introduce you i'd take a
nap tommy pope everybody what's up boys
what's up buddy thanks for coming in man
yeah it's always great to see foley's
tongue in person
i think's got a [ __ ] heartbeat of its
own oh man all the comments on youtubers
like the big man's tongue is going wild
today it is it's like going to like uh
like a japanese
seafood market you know when you see a
fish or like a squid
yeah i've never seen that before foley's
down on the docks every morning in tokyo
dude i want to be in your wheel i want
your tongue i'll put that thing in a
[ __ ] glass cube on my dresser
turn it into a love seat splice a little
soy sauce on it
ain't too shabby dude i got a merch idea
for you why don't you guys make uh bean
bags put
foliage face on it and when you sit the
pressure throws out a tongue
maybe throw his laugh in there that
might be a logistical nightmare but i'll
have the guys look into it
that's the shipping and handling
nightmare man oh buddy
thanks for [ __ ] tuning in with us
thanks for coming in and sitting down
with us you got your uh your home depot
shirt on
i find one t-shirt i like i buy 17
colors same way it's always black for me
though
that's garbage and that's old school i
[ __ ] well i do the same thing
i'm currently operating but you only
have one of everything you own don't
[ __ ] lie down it's not true i got a
bunch of these t-shirts unless every
t-shirt comes with mustard stains
they get some pre-owned certified you
can find them on amazon squirt some mayo
on these before you send them
hey sprinkle the chips right on there
that's fine it's like a stamp of
approval
patreon questions facebook questions
before we get started i'm told i got a
call this morning from
corporate from up top top floor yeah
that mr ryan
has a statement to make and before we
get into the questions we're going to
start off with that i will turn it over
to our ceo i normally kevin ryan
you know it's hard for me to admit when
i'm wrong all the time
right oh it's okay i take very staunch
opinions on the on this program as we
both do
fair enough and i've had the uh the
attorneys in corporate draft a statement
for me to make as i've
changed my ways okay how i see the world
did you touch someone
this is pretty dark hey doobie dobrik
whatever you're
doing first of all i thought she was 17.
she was well developed like a 23 year
old
hang on a second let me move my chair
over oh yeah i don't know if that's
testosterone or the chickens
but she had a side of hooters i want to
move my chair over away from you from
getty image purposes
i don't want to get hemmed up in the
post
because he's making a stamped creep on
both of our faces
she found herself drunk in the basement
of a titties
what do you got all right so my
statements made on previous
podcasts regarding brushing your teeth
in the shower have been wrong
and i sincerely apologize to anyone i've
affected
with my words while my words of time
were said to shame and hurt people
especially my fat co-host foley
i now know i was wrong please accept my
apology wait a second are you saying
you're for it i'm four i was
totally against it kevin i started doing
it doing it this week i saw it sitting
there i'm like i'll try it
for the show it's a [ __ ] game-changer
dude it's great
i actually was the same way this
quarantine is so 40 years i went without
doing this because
i was garbage yeah i put i got i got a
[ __ ] you're wait you're 40.
yeah you look ten you slept with three
you slept with three of your brothers
until you were 20.
that's garbage took another 12 years to
figure it out
no i got a separate tube and a separate
toothbrush just do you leave it in there
though
oh that's that's tough i don't i can't
do that that's a lot
no well you'll be writing another
[ __ ] apology in a week
i'm still going through with the lawsuit
all right
the defamation get portland on the phone
i want some d's major dude it's a game
changer you get out and it's complete i
never
realized yeah you [ __ ] jerk off you
know what it comes down to like
i growing up i thought if you leave the
conditioner in longer your hair will be
more healthy yeah so i find things to do
while you're in there yeah i put the
conditioner on first and then i
you know it's working i gotta tell you
this
the longer i left the conditioner and
the flatter my hair was really oh it was
like oh cause you got dirt and old
grease in there well i got thin hair
yeah
yeah it's the only thing thin about them
folks it was pre-product yeah i didn't
surprise you condition
yeah well i would say you never i would
i would say you've never washed your
hair once i wash my hair every day
every day he's got that good italian
hair dude
that's ridiculous that the whole [ __ ]
because it looks so
full and in place and that's what people
do they don't wash their hair
to get that fullness what do you use use
the good stuff
yeah like how whatever candles
my mom's got a couple of yankees laying
around
smells like apples and cinnamon in the
winter
sebastian clay it's like how much is it
like 20 bucks for one ounce
it's a lot 20. that's more than coke no
[Laughter]
crews about 22. yeah cruise expensive i
i do the cruise spray i think it's like
15.
yeah dude i'm great tommy and i are
talking here
you touching me hurt me more than
anything more than the joke you being
like oh man he might be affected by that
it really hurts
he washes his hair with his toothbrush
i got a baby i got baby bristles
this is a hot one folks so that's your
statement so you're brushing your teeth
in the shower now i knew
i knew things are gonna go screwy
because kippy's solo right now he's got
the place to himself for a little while
the broad went back home and you're
you're you're stepping out of your
element you're doing a little
experimenting in that place
yeah yeah i'm all over the place what
made you decide to brush your teeth in
the shower
well i've never it's never been close
and then it i can
i can kind of get to it from the shower
now like the way my
and i just saw it there and i was like
you know what for the pot i'll try it
and i'll i'll [ __ ] throw it in your
face and i'll hate it and we'll get
content out of it
dude i was like two seconds into i was
on like my [ __ ] second molar and i
was like this is not too shabby
then he spit it all out and it turned
out
get that coolness in there i got one
more for you
i could take it up a notch if you want
you could do it in the shower or
in the sink say eat nachos
i'll [ __ ] dive over this table what
you do is get a bag of tortillas yeah
you'd be surprised they don't suck up as
fast
if you get the water hot enough to miss
it gets the cheese yeah gives it a good
consistency
you gotta drink lemonade while you're
taking a piss it's like the same going
insane going out
brush your teeth with hot water it feels
like you just have them polished it's
fantastic
all right you feel clean in the mouth
feels great i'm a cold water guy huh
i don't know i don't know you want from
me i'm trying to listen i'm trying to
[ __ ] save you the embarrassment
having to come in here
[ __ ] six months crying at a [ __ ]
audience again telling them that uncle
hank was right
i don't know i mean i don't like the way
this was received so i don't know if
i'll ever be publicly apologizing again
that's really turned back on me
yeah you never apologize you don't know
you were [ __ ]
whatever that's what it is i'm a changed
man i'm a reformed man
you think you'll continue to do it after
even after your wife gets home not every
time but yeah
you know how's she going to feel about
that i think she has to be she's done it
she has to be a shower brusher as well
she's a shower brusher and a non-shower
brusher cannot exist
immediate divorce she does it
occasionally she's not against it
she's not opposed to it by any means
she's definitely done it she'll be goose
stepping back in germany
this man is gross
in the shower since a very short time
i will miss his hair though so will i
tommy how are you i'm good buddy i feel
good
you're really turn regis sometimes and
tommy how are you keep saying that
he's our guest i know well we're [ __ ]
14 minutes into the show and i know he's
lying because i can tell he's hanging on
by a thin thread over there
what do you want me to do tell you the
truth get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
supposed to be having fun
bringing up the truth yeah [ __ ] i
thought we were supposed to here to hang
out okay my dad just said bypass surgery
and i i drank so much place i don't [ __ ]
myself this morning at the gym yeah i
got a little [ __ ] going on on
on holy thursday yeah that's right yeah
i throw out all my khakis just in case
because spring's coming
i got swamp ass out the [ __ ] nights
oh man why'd you throw it on your khakis
i can't wear light-colored pants in the
summer which things show
my monkey butt is outrageous i go three
blocks and i start
you know it's a mess yeah it's not good
you're sitting on the subway you're
feeling it roasting
don't think about it and then it starts
stripping like yeah then you're like
dude do i feel that then you're gonna
stand up
sometimes i'll take a picture
[Applause]
it never does and i'm always wrong but
it feels it but it feels like it's
there well you gotta it's gotta get
through the underwear layer the
underwear is thicker than we give
ourselves credit for yeah yeah yeah
you guys butt sweats that much oh yeah
especially like auditions and [ __ ]
who are you i don't get that [ __ ] out of
here
dude the things you take opinion yeah
you're ooh that's great
toby these guys are gross huh dude the
one time we were eating sandwiches in a
while
parking lot he goes oh my god you're
eating so fast i'm like oh i'm doing the
thing you wish you could do
you can never get in fast fully the
sweat just can't escape your cavernous
ass dude
yeah it's true it really can't well my i
get backed up in the center that's where
i get my moisture that's my that's my
little race what the [ __ ] is this center
i don't know
yeah we don't have we don't have size i
don't have a hemisphere okay
i don't have a family room in my crotch
now you take a walk to the living room
yeah the florida room
there's another room for those two they
were always cooking hot rooms the sun
room yeah
but they call it a floor room indoor
ride
yeah yeah it's a real garbage place
yeah yeah yeah smaller parents have one
smells like signs
oh you got one dude his literally smells
not the way he's
talking does yours have like the the
oval kind of windows where you can no
it's a
uh block it smells like the the floor of
a vfw because
the moisture gets in you know insects
get in oh we might we have one
it's like a tent it's a [ __ ] house
can you find some pension bugs out there
but yeah
some rolly pollies for sure
[Laughter]
i don't like that at all oh yeah that's
trashy man
okay all right let's let's shift gears
let's get into some [ __ ] some uh
patreon questions guys so as you know
when you join the patreon we will answer
your questions
uh we have a little bit of a backlog
we're really cranking through some of
them but we're going to get to everybody
uh and also when you leave your question
let us know that if you're new and you
haven't had it as yet and we'll
uh you know we'll prioritize you a bit
um or you could just shut up and be
patient yeah
i got the enforcer over unbelievable
that was a
repressed memory right there nobody
asked my question yeah shut up dildo
this is free
[Laughter]
let these slow dildos hear it customer's
always right
best customer service and podcasting by
the way that's right we'll get back to
you um
this one i i can't foresee either one of
you doing it but it is a home run of a
[ __ ] question this is from timothy
have you ever hung a sports jersey on
the wall on a hanger
of course on a hanger yeah my bed in my
bedroom my dad wouldn't let me put a
[ __ ] nail
uh you know he wouldn't let me pin it up
four ways and they're not gonna pay for
me to get a frame
boom and it hangs flat yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah lenny dykstra
that was my next question von hayes
hayes one too and then uh my quick
oh man mike mikey old school yeah what
kind of hanger were they on
uh metal so it was shitty it was before
the plastics
these are the ones these are heavy duty
yeah your mom would have to dry clean a
fancy shirt once a year and
save them for [ __ ] take off that we
love our costumes yeah yeah
punch right through it yeah dude hitting
somebody with one of those was game
there's like those game shows you could
smash through and see what's in the ball
we were just talking about that
we just talked about it last episode
shout out to plinko
have you ever i've never i don't think
we've ever hung a jersey no i wasn't a
big i threw a couple pennants up
stuff like that i was like yeah it was a
penta guy too i didn't roll like that
yeah did you leave the stick in for the
pennants
the stick no you had to take this out
yeah i had
[Laughter]
every when you go out you just waving on
the front lawn shirtless
i don't even remember getting them with
with sticks in them yeah oh you order
them online you [ __ ] suck
i don't know where we got it you got to
earn it you got to go to the stadium
yeah get it
get it from the guy in the shopping cart
you got to fight the fight the popcorn
guy
they're coming taped up dildo they're
supposed to be held here yours came in a
box
i can't remember we definitely didn't
have sticks on them and we certainly
didn't leave them on the display
we had a couple of flyers once i
remember with the sticks for a long time
but then you always i felt like we
always hit
each other with the sticks like that
turned it you know you got bored waving
it and you're like what else can i
[ __ ] do it
who else who can i hurt with this thing
it was typically most of the 90s
can this fit up my ass that was always
that was always the problem on little
bat night [ __ ] oh my god
oh dude you wear it quick dude you wear
them from the tri-state area if you
didn't have a trenton thunder a mini
trenton thunderback
first of all the little the bat night
just turned into like they call them
beaters for like your car
yeah like how often are you getting
[ __ ] road rage bat flashes
you need it right there you pull them
out you have a sword fight accessible
yeah yeah they're the same game
they're the same game 10 years ago holy
[ __ ] are you joey from 24c
he still hits him in the face i didn't
think you stepped on my shoe when he
went to the pantry yeah
no i don't use a little bass number i
ran to a guy with a full-size louisville
yeah
i used to have a louisville in the trunk
just i don't know what i was going to do
with it nothing it wasn't batting
practice it was cool to hear that
yeah it was also cool like when you were
like getting beer out of the trunk with
somebody at a party
like yeah just you know i got the louie
if anybody needs it
put some duct tape on it there's no
goddamn reason my name was
that's good you have evidence you know
did kevin james ryan
oh ma'am great home run home run of the
question
um i'm gonna defer this you were you
worked in the
just caught you looking around i was
well there's a bahamas pennant there see
where you could put it i know they they
vetoed it
they vetoed the pennant who did it these
two bozos we just haven't found the
right spot yet
your jersey made it on the wall yeah god
damn right there
we should put it on a hanger um
you worked in service industry right uh
one year one year i thought you were
like a bartender or
a later kind of guy that's not true i
was yeah i was a bartender where's he
looking right now
i'm locked into the bahamas thing i
think it's [ __ ] beautiful it's coming
home with me
you guys have no respect for you put on
that come filled countdown dustin
hoffman over here
papa ridley and get focused we're
broadcasting here it's like
an eye test what the [ __ ] are you doing
when i
just before i started comedy
[Laughter]
hey gang quick announcement from one of
our brand new sponsors fume
took a look around the world and noticed
that solutions that quit smoking like
patches and nicotine inhaler
kind of stunk i used the gum a bunch of
times i hated it it cuts up your mouth
you feel like an idiot popping gum all
the time
so in response fume handcrafted these
beautiful little wooden pipes to make
the quitting process simple
easy and even desirable it's not a corny
vape or anything like that it doesn't
use nicotine but instead uses these
cores infused
with the world's super plants you slide
it right in the front there there's
different flavors
and they help you successfully quit from
start to finish plus they taste
pretty good too uh so head over to
www.breathfume.com
that's t h b-r-e-a-t-h-e f
u m.com and use promo code garbage
the link will be in the description of
the show check out the variety of plant
infused cores to start today
they're conquer their conquer cores are
the number one core for quitting smoking
from start to finish so get involved
with these people
they sent us over to us we we've been
using them t-bone uses them i use them
fully uses them it's already helped over
30
000 customers worldwide with hundreds of
customers who have shared their quitting
stories on their site go
check it out www.breathefume.com that's
b-r-e-a-t-h-f-u-m.com use promo code
garbage and save yourself 10 percent
and help somebody quit today now back
to the show uh 26 i walked in i had a
full-time job i walked into this bar
that was opening up um public house
remember that in philly it was a real
big joint the public house yeah where
the [ __ ] was that it was on 18th and uh
cherry maybe yeah yeah yeah and um
i i'm an old person an old friend of
mine from drexel
was a manager and i was like this place
is great it's hard to get into
and she's like would you ever want a
bartender and this is you know the peak
of like
you know i'm 26. i'm almost out of the
area of like going out and getting
trimming and hanging out and too late
you know i'm getting
too hard for that yeah and you're in the
deep end of the pool
correct you say trim yeah i did so what
are you magnum pi
see
[Laughter]
bring two buckets i'm hungry tonight
we're gonna go score some muff huh what
are you saying
i'm was getting something eating at home
i worked there for a year and it was the
best time of my life
and then when i said what year was this
i'm sorry 2006.
2006 cities probably popping that place
was probably nice it was probably
[ __ ]
real fun two years open it was [ __ ]
amazing
oh coat closets bar bar backs
it was nuts it's a regular restaurant
okay yeah yeah
it was nuts bus boys and then uh
not his place was nice i'm telling you
they had a busboy hey somebody only
worked weekends but still
the sodas were carbonated some kind of
computer system where if you call we'd
pick up i don't know a phone
i meant i meant bartenders oh
it's like 4 30. no i'm talking to him
he's swung and missed all right
you stink too though we're being honest
and then i worked in the kitchen i
worked in a byo when i first started
comedy just because i was uh interested
in cooking
so i worked for a year in a byo italian
in south philly then i worked in the
pepperoncinis in um in phoenixville for
a year very nice okay
how [ __ ] boring was that huh no no
that gets into this this is
cause you're i know you're you you
waited tables for like 20 years yeah
stop reading the questions
you two look at each other that's why
i'm looking down this way
you guys are got to [ __ ] wandering
eyes this week yeah i turned the table
or two that's right
uh all right well you might have sold
some specials in my time you worked at a
fish place in written house right i
worked at devon seafood yeah for a while
the aquarium
yeah that's how we got our perk guide
isn't it
i'm sorry are you talking to me yeah my
eyes aren't wandering now are they
yeah toby mark that minute mark it's
going to be a hard cut
out of restaurants i'll tell you that
it's like bobby darren over here
singing [ __ ] zigzag on the yes that's
that that was how we uh
yeah fell into that man
i'm gonna let you two just hang yourself
out the drive when i was snorting black
tar we popped the temper
he didn't work there burnt to the garage
in the alley
he fully comes fully turns the corner
they're flipping pigeons
all right this is from dan uh if you pay
for dinner on a credit card
then tip in cash is that classy or
trashy it's classy as it gets
right yeah that's cause you're thinking
about the other person
because they don't pay taxes on that but
don't don't they don't have to pay the
restaurant don't you have to turn your
tips in
i've worked at some places where they
like to collect them all [ __ ] lie
please go yeah i made uh 40 bucks
tonight okay another 80. yeah i don't
know i never really did i bust
tables in like high school in college
but that was it because when you put it
on the card you could just put
you just put cash cash and they don't
know the amount so say they leave you 40
you then turn in 20. yes
if they ask yes or you could [ __ ] over
your co-worker that you don't like
that's been
annoying you for listening if it's big
with you dirtball if it's a pulled house
yeah yeah man it's brutal oh forget
about it yeah i was in my opinion my
eyes
[Laughter]
always a girl because they can't get hit
slow night tonight huh
but that's what they thought anyway i
had a thick softball bruiser that would
[ __ ] lay down
with this other girl that was stealing
you had a few
enforcer yeah she was she was the one
working tables and this little hot
[ __ ]
blonde uh was working behind the bar and
i knew she was stealing and i was like
look just do me a favor and warn her
because
she was like from northeast she was a
real [ __ ] real irish fish
you have to break the break
just a big freckle monster i knew she
[ __ ] if she's
the homer and softball she can right
hook this pig
probably came in with wet hair all the
time always running late yeah i know
exactly what you're talking about
smelling like that purple uh hairspray
candy yeah but if she is or something
yeah but if she liked it she had a
kangaroo had a kangaroo on it yeah
it was like three bucks for [ __ ] 74
ounces to [ __ ] ruin the ozone with
two sprays
yeah that's why they weren't really
cared the australians didn't care about
the environment so it's gonna be 200
degrees next week
all these white trash [ __ ] from
northeast [ __ ] spraying their bangs
trying to go for 4 5. dude there's
nothing trashier than wet crunchy hair
from the northeast
well there was a weird thing when a lot
of uh especially irish i
bust as a kid i i don't know why that
made me sick to my stomach seeing that
yeah anybody with wet hair
wet scrunchy hair that's like frozen
with this smell like strawberries
rotten strawberries yeah tough luck
tough luck ah here's the thing
that's a that's a very old-school
mentality of doing that because the
that originated with people people
almost being embarrassed
that they had to pay with the card and
not didn't have full cash
so that was always i've always
encountered this with like old-school
people like old-school mom's like
i'm sorry i'm putting on the card but
i'm tipping it in i'm always being with
us
she feels bad that she's even putting
the thing on a car yeah yeah yeah
i want to make sure that you get your
money i don't want you also too
she doesn't realize now that yeah it's
most most
restaurants are pulled houses and all
that kind of [ __ ] so i was always
i was older and they banged yeah under
the impression you had to i guess maybe
in the early days you had to wait to get
that money or did that restaurant always
give you that money
i mean back in the day back you had to
wait like a couple days until the credit
card processed it and then you
sure yeah no that's why your paycheck
like your next paycheck in two weeks
yeah
you got to wait the whole thing yeah we
were always got tip there was always
like we'll put on the car but i'll
[ __ ]
some places are different but usually
you take your cash to your take your
cash tips that night
and then you get your [ __ ] check out
then leave which they do bang you out on
but most restaurants now when it comes
to taxes they there's just a number
you know what i mean or they [ __ ]
claim every single thing that you have
so that doesn't really work anymore but
it's very sweet to do that i'm gonna put
a helmet on for how boring this [ __ ]
story is
here at ayg enterprises we pay all of
our taxes
uh all right next question coming in uh
this is from
uh this is from joe have you ever had a
catch outside with an autographed ball
no hell no dude well it's funny that's
money in the bank right yeah
we had i brought this down there's a
bait there's a world series or an
all-star ball signed by like two
nobodies
that like was our that was like our
college fund we thought when we were
kids
and then i brought it here i put it in
it's in it's in plastic and he took it
out and i like
my childhood just ringing i'm like dude
put that back put that back
don't [ __ ] that up yeah that's gary
stevenson
it was like terry francona [ __ ] rory
mulholland or somebody
two [ __ ] zilches i felt bad like even
my
personal balls were like you know how
you'd have you collect like your first
home run ball sure
like even throwing around with those i
felt like they felt nervous yeah of
course you felt rich
were you a kid that would uh would you
would you ask for autographs and [ __ ]
like that would you be hanging around
the place that's one of these
that's one of the questions my first
autograph i'll never forget i was
watching an eagles practice
my dad took me on the watch a lot oh my
god yo that's a that should be a
question do you go to watch
the training facility yuki washington
shout out to you
my boy you still around yeah oh yeah and
i i saw him i met him in the [ __ ]
legend
me and mckeever had to do this talk for
delco and it was uh
every conversation you two have you mean
at the uh no no shut up
this is out front it was like a a philly
organized thing where he had uh he had
to talk
as well he was like m night shyamalan
yeah all the philly see there's the
celebs m night shyamalan
what was the weather guy busy
the philly fanatics ex-wife who i slept
with that night
no yeah and i thanked him i was like
you're my very first autograph and he
was like the sweetest
wait yuki washington yeah on what
football
wait you had you you had the [ __ ]
sports i thought he was dr
j when you're [ __ ] eight years old of
course that might as well be the
president that's
yeah that's the guy you see him oh yeah
every night he's reporting the news
him vernon odom was big garlic
no uh who was the tim gardner was big
jim gardner looks exactly like my dad uh
papa
the guy that just died gary popper harry
potter yeah papa yeah
vice
he used to play and then when he started
doing the sports it was like [ __ ] oh
yeah
action six was the a team oh forget
about it they had it all
under lock there's also there's the
there's the dude that uh
he's the sports guy the big tall guy now
john something
oh clark yeah big good looking like you
know you know yeah
uh you don't like him everybody hates
him dude
he used to show up to kavanaugh's on
drexel's campus when we were in college
and hit on everybody's girlfriend he's a
he's like a mainline douche yeah
you know he wears like boat shoes and
[ __ ] salmon pants
yeah he's a real [ __ ] dildo he threw
away the public house buddy
yeah yeah dude he threw a lemon across
the bar at my body and hit him in the
head
get the [ __ ] out of capitals on drexel's
campus and it was almost he's like
because we used to [ __ ] we used to call
him the weather guy and he [ __ ] hated
it
we'd be like yeah whatever weather man
what's it going to be like this weekend
i'm the sport dude he couldn't take the
jokes which like we just leaned into
a lemon wedge or a full lemon lemon
wedge like from the ball like maybe from
his drink or from the thing
right in the [ __ ] head dude and my
buddy went blizzy trying to get over the
ball it was a whole [ __ ] yeah you
take the shortcut
i'm [ __ ] die bomb in that dude's
you're getting worked right in the
middle that's on him though what are you
doing hanging out in a [ __ ]
college cause he's looking for he's like
he thinks he's a celebrity he's gonna
pull some 23 year old i got you but you
got you're you're in there with the
hyenas
now i gotta unfollow him and [ __ ]
apologize he's not gonna hear this
i don't know we're pretty big especially
in the tri-state area
t-bone bleep the name all right about
the big story in action news tonight
tommy pope was talking [ __ ]
that was actually about glenn hurricane
schwartz everybody
imagine giving him a wedgie and jamming
on the wall
oh man oh great question this is a
bonkos one baby we're all over the place
um all right let's see
this is from jack rush have you ever
left six out to dry
when they got there no you got to be in
a tough spot
and they have the brown liquid [ __ ]
you guys like in the pack or like rolls
into something it doesn't matter you got
to be in a tough spot
i've done it for sure man i mean that's
back against the wall
picking up a [ __ ] cigarette these
days like if it's down it's down oh
dude oh dude you gotta [ __ ] i got
i don't know what to happen in this
country tommy's in front of a seven can
i get kills on
it's like this short relight and a
[ __ ] one inch
there's sparks going everywhere dude
queens that's all there are
like this dude just looking in pots and
trying to find uh you know
a wet cigarette man it's [ __ ] bad but
i've been there
where it gets a hole in it and you like
hold it like this oh i've done that you
can still get
[Laughter]
well you could lose the front half of
that and still be good those things are
you lose the front half it's like you
can share it with the neighborhood if
you wanted to
dude you liked that on tuesday you
finished it on saturday night
dude you're like a fish puffing on that
thing i feel like nemo
trying to [ __ ] catch a light brutal
that's so funny
um all right well yeah that was actually
questions from claire have you ever
waited outside for an autograph
um yeah hold on i want to go back to
that because i imagine
just from what i know about sure and you
were closer to the city
yeah you were that you would go to like
did you ever get on a spring training or
anything like this
they took you down there when you were a
kid yeah i went to bethlehem for spring
training before
oh really or for yeah yeah yeah iron
pigs iron pigs
no well the eagles used to practice oh
really they used to report up there and
we went i remember i thought
in my head it felt like four and a four
hour drive and then i got there i'm like
it was like four i'm like i don't know
he's [ __ ] people
dude imagine like taking the train to
the city it was like 30 minutes and
you thought it was like a [ __ ] awful
yeah i
ordered a stromboli from a [ __ ] greek
joint the night before wrapped it up
my dad's like it's 45 minutes dildo took
three naps yeah
i think i was going to the zoo on a
school trip
yeah i would go to spring training or um
eagles practices like once or twice a
year and then um
as a kid yeah would you try to win hey
yeah yeah and then you'd wait til all
these guys came out you'd only get
signed by
yeah and then uh but i noticed him
walking to his car
and i just started screaming yuki and i
ran to him with a football like uh you
know like a
rom-com i didn't turn around signed it
you know
nice man pretty sweet remember what kind
of whip he was in no he never got to the
car
oh i had wheels dude because i was
[ __ ] ran him down quick i was on sick
once i set my sights i closed yeah he
had no shot at getting that
trans am whatever the goddamn thing was
hey where you going big guy
i'm sure it's like a firebird or
something risque because he's so
uptight because i pulled up next to
vernon odom one time and he was driving
a [ __ ] cadillac
that would blow your hair back oh i'm
sure it looked like it was made in 2024
it was [ __ ] top shelf he's got
features like
mr potato head is that home thick enough
is he a football player i can't that's
caster vernon the older oh yeah
visions on saturday on saturday
afternoon
in the evening uh while we're on the
subject this is from ben
uh do you keep stadium souvenir beer
cups in regular rotation at your house
absolutely really
absolutely because that was your that
was your chance to get a bigger ounce a
big a big thing
or whatever it was yeah it was either
beach cups pizza hut cups that you stole
oh yeah or we have them over there or
the beer koozies from the from the parks
yeah those were the [ __ ]
i remember having like a set of flyers
play-off watching yes dude they were
for 15 years they were at the house yeah
and for a good one to two year period
they were the same octagonal shape and
they would slide right in so you could
stack three to five oh yeah
otherwise you've got no real estate
otherwise you're jamming up the worst
that's what mom and dad have we gotta
get rid of these cops
all the [ __ ] you know all the art is
always all fantastic
yeah if you had those displayed around
like you know oh
you're trash that's garbage oh man yeah
that's a [ __ ]
i don't think i've ever gone over it
recently i've gone over to anybody's
house and that's what they've given me
right now i'm doing i still like i kind
of have the same mentality i use like um
you know like the ninja or like any of
those blenders yeah come with the
back up yeah i take the lid off and then
i just use that for
water my wife does that oh really yeah
cause it's like 32 ounces
it's a it's a big boy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah dude it's real bad if
you're at a homie's place you're
watching like a hawks game or something
and they pull out the stadium cup and
they're wearing the jersey
watching the game at the house that's a
tough that's unacceptable behavior hey
scroll up dude that's a tough
like all colors to a stadium even if
it's a game like if you're if you got a
hat and a jersey and [ __ ]
calm down if you're i mean also if
you're on the couch eating soft serve
out of a little plastic
baseball hat you get dressed up at home
get the [ __ ] out you got the foam finger
in the living room i mean you're
you're talking a big game but i bumped
into you the day after
i bumped into you on the train the day
after the eagles won the super bowl
and we were coming back up hold on we
were hold on we were coming back up to
new york
this is 100 true yeah we were coming
back up to new york
he's i see him on the train like fried
like he had gone
he like blinked that was his sleep for
the night and he's like hey man you're
coming back down for
for the parade tomorrow and i'm like i
don't think i'm gonna make it man
and he's like meanwhile i think i got
work tonight smells like a bar rag he's
like
he's going yeah i mean i'm trying to
figure out what i'm gonna wear because
it's gonna be cold and
we want to be able to fit as much
jameson bottles on us as possible
i'm like he's like i think we're going
to get the little ones because they
curve around your leg
all right tom i'll see you later pal oh
my god hey conductor can you see this
guy's got a ticket
oh my god dude i came at him
small town boy makes good look at you
my wife goes who do you have on the
podcast ago i go the good looking guy
from the train
[Laughter]
i scared the [ __ ] out of here oh he got
me well he saw me go to the bathroom and
then i'm walking back to my seat and he
came up like
he had drunk uncle energy oh my god and
i was [ __ ] all over as a judge
look at your little [ __ ] look who it is
just hitting your dick in front of your
wife oh
there's a little guy doing ah just
completely blitzed out of my mind
hi as [ __ ] he bumped out like blueprints
about how what jameson bottles he's
gonna die
the horrified look on your wi-fi i never
remember she's like are we getting
robbed
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
right now but no he's a friend i swear
yeah i know he's giving me a wedgie but
he's a friend
i'm joking you're coming to the parade
why were you going back up for one night
and then coming back down for the parade
probably get pills
or something i probably just got on the
wrong [ __ ] train
i thought he was going home yeah yeah i
don't know i'm talking about kippy what
are you doing in baltimore
i probably [ __ ] my pants i was like i
gotta go home
no it was [ __ ] yeah yeah and that's
like it's the super bowl
[Laughter]
i swear to god when i was getting
dressed and you're right i was getting
dressed and i was like is this too much
because i had a green t-shirt on but i
put a sweatshirt over it just so you
could see the top and the bottom and
then i had it because you're not an
[ __ ]
yeah that's not a parade yet then the
shoulder pads in the helmet
party he had the black lines was a
little much
wearing the jock outside of the jeans
maybe driving through the parade in a
golf cart
[Laughter]
oh dressed like andy reed oh that's
fantastic
but the parade was [ __ ] wild man that
was so funny i didn't do we just did we
were at like the riot the night before
or whatever we all like
everything that's that's how trashy you
are when someone
when the when a team in philadelphia
wins when phillies won and when the
eagles won
there's something in innately in your
dirt bag dna
that you're just drawn to city hall
everybody 100
ever dude because it's in the center of
the city everybody from the tri-state
area just [ __ ]
converges like it's a bug zapper yeah
everybody
also if you had the drive so i watched
it in delco because the bars are empty
in delco yeah and also
i'm sure it's the same in monco and
whatever box when you uh
when the games get more important you
don't watch them in a bar you're
watching you want to ruin the living
room because you don't want
any strangers around you have a nice
seat you got to [ __ ] your own
controlled environment
sure and i knew no one would be there we
had a corner of uh barnaby's
in uh drexel hill it was beautiful and
then we all get in the car but all you
see is all you see is all the cars it's
like bumping cars with drunks getting
down yeah to the city yeah it's [ __ ]
lawless
it's the cops are like [ __ ] i don't give
a [ __ ] dude literally when we were down
there we were down there in the [ __ ]
chaos and
um it was like me my wife a couple other
buddies and like their girlfriend
we were like all right like we were
older we're like uh we've seen enough
like
yeah it's starting to get a little dicey
and then no like as we said that
five guys walk by with a telephone pole
over their shoulders like
but like they were carrying a piece of
lumber and i'm like i think it's time to
wrap it up
you guys are ordering dessert
we'll share a tiramisu oh my god when
the blackhawks won the cup for the first
time
we were down in wrigley we were down in
raleyville and i saw a group of dudes
shotgunning 24-ounce tall boys i was
like [ __ ] yeah i love that
and then i saw guys coming out of a head
shop that they had looted
and a guy had a six-foot glass bong just
running down the street no way that made
it home
no but i was like i was like this is
great dude a sports riot i mean i love
that [ __ ]
yeah but also like i'll say the thing
about like how trashy philly is we were
in the phillies riot
and randomly saw another group of my
buddies yeah who was like up kind of on
a telephone pole
kind of not whatever yeah and uh
but you couldn't get there and i was
like yo that's my boy and everybody's
like oh [ __ ] you know him i'm like yeah
they're like and then like
they just let us go because they were
like oh they're friends they got to get
back together like
everybody was so polite during the rise
100 yeah i went to the parade and some
you know the cement blocks that are
over top of a a gas station wait what
that protects that you've already admit
you've already confessed to three crimes
so far so what do you mean well they
made a change that pulled people up so
they pulled us up to the top
cement so you can get a look at the
parade coming through broad street wait
on top of the
on top of the cement block that that
protects for weather protection
so like the roof of the outside yeah
i've never heard a roof referred to as
cement blocks
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
go get me a bag who has paul for some
more
that was such a real name paul
nobody hangs out with a paul unless he's
got a connection true
oh man paul ain't getting a desk
paul knows his way around a weed whack
or a coke
[Laughter]
pulls a lot of keys on him for some
reason he doesn't drive
oh uh all right this one's from facebook
this was a home run from [ __ ]
facebook this is from scott
is it garbage to leave your shoes in the
hallway outside your apartment door
you know what i'm i i'm biased on this
okay
because this quarantine's been a new i i
i take them off as soon as you get in
but i never used to be a shoeless family
i just look at you know you were shoes
in the house growing up yeah
yeah no well not like we carpet so we
take them off not bad it wasn't illegal
it wasn't like sure yeah it wasn't all
tommy take your shoes here
no wasn't any of that but my father as
soon as you woke up he i've never seen
my fat
my dad's teeth his wife's feet i've
never seen her seen his dad's feet
i swear to god he's shoes as soon as he
gets up it's
it's a it's a white trash thing where
you feel like you got to get moving what
kind of shoes is he rocking oh [ __ ]
serial killer fours
because he is oh white
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] never had a collar on
a foot
he looks like he's about to clean a
[ __ ] cafeteria yeah the air
responsible
yes dude it's crazy because
you know now they're in like the
all-white chunky [ __ ]
yeah they're cool yeah and also like
yeah stonewashed levi's and [ __ ] so
every 10 years he's doing it every 10
years
he wears denim on denim like pop this is
you could go anywhere right now and look
legit yeah
public house but then like another five
years goes by like take it easy killer
check for blood stains oh that's so
[ __ ] funny
he puts his shoes on right away no it is
a tactic it's a white trash tactic
because you feel like you you got to get
moving you got to get moving yeah yeah
and also he did
he set his alarm like three minutes
before he had to be at the [ __ ] box
just one stop for a coffee to play he
wasn't a slipper guy i take it
no oh my god you've seen his mustache
those guys don't wear [ __ ] slippers
you're dead yeah your dad's got a stash
on him yeah your dad is blue
his blue collar is against that field he
had a bypass surgery didn't today so
shout out pop
shout out pop quick healing or else i'm
shaving that [ __ ] thing off
putting it in a glass cube
[Laughter]
guys if you join the 100 patreon you get
tommy's dad's mustache
and foley's tongue oh god i'm sweating
well my wife started doing the shoes
outside the hallway which i don't
approve of
yeah what's the rug situation when you
come in i'm sorry i keep doing this like
a [ __ ] grandma but it's nice
it's okay although also that's what we
were [ __ ] on beforehand
yeah yeah if you're putting the shoes
outside there better be a
there better be a rug out there we gotta
rock out that rug out there is not used
properly then right unless everybody
goes by the rules
you can walk outside you're putting new
york [ __ ] bottoms on a rug that
you're then putting your socks on
and throw the socks out that's a smart
man he that you operate under the same
rules i do it's disgusting the more you
think about it you're taking these
[ __ ] sneakers they're walking through
all these homeless [ __ ] piss
blood [ __ ] yeah and then you're just
throwing it right on a rug where you're
where you're eating in a two-hour
period maybe one for you
[Laughter]
20 minutes for you look over here he's
eating his shoe yeah he untucks a piece
of pizza out of his pocket
he got me thinking about that now though
yeah no pizza
[Laughter]
no it's once you get it in your head
that'll make you change we we wipe and
we wipe our shoes we wipe our fingers
clip your ass before you get in can't
run a couch
we wipe our feet on on the rug before we
get in we step in
on to another rug take our shoes off
and then and then go and put them over
to the side that's okay i like that move
but see
outside like the roach or something
could crawl
into it a mouse or something could get
in there a spider
oh you mean outdoors you know he means
i'm outside of the apartment
not like a [ __ ] i'm not leaving him
out on the street
hey nobody touched these converses dude
i put eight pairs of [ __ ] sneakers
out the other day and they were gone in
like an hour
really yeah and it's side street and in
some you know in queens a story just to
get rid of them
just get rid of them yeah because my
girl was like throwing stuff in trash
cans i was like go put it outside it
doesn't matter one thing in new york you
put it outside people take the [ __ ]
right away i took a [ __ ] ninja
i ordered a new blender i put it right
on the curve oh i thought it meant like
a figurine or something
kind of motif you got going on at the
house well you got to hang it right next
to the pennants
i put an old it's it's running on the
[ __ ] one leg dude and it was still
gone
just gone it's like as long as you don't
put it in the trash area they know it's
it's
it's still usable most most buildings if
you keep it in the building
like you know bigger apartment companies
have like a place like the mailboxes
they know to look over here this is
where we take our [ __ ] or if you're
outside they do see i walked by like
three or four pairs of ladies shoes out
in front of a door and they were in them
they were i just need the left one
no i got into again i walked right by
and i was gonna take him but then i was
like yeah and i got scared
i stopped putting them outside because
we now have to put our recycling there
because this [ __ ]
heroin kid go roots through everybody's
trash the night before recycling so you
can't put your bottles and cans
out on the street out because they
decide yeah that we have a side
compartment he opens the front gate
walks back there rips the [ __ ] cans
the bags open believes that yeah
mayhem so now i got to sit these which
sometimes leak oh yeah
you never caught this kid no but one
time i did and i did that thing like
my dad does this thing where he combines
seven words in the one like you like if
you said get out of there when you were
kidding like yeah
yeah so yeah like you're talking to a
horse or something if i hear him
on the side rattle and go yeah and then
he carries
yeah he's scared grabs his son kiss and
then he's like you know he's you're
yelling at him over the window yeah
yeah yeah heroin adds don't get phased
by much
um i saw one guy it was just so funny i
don't know he was drunk or something
yesterday i was walking down 42nd street
and he was out front of a subway
sandwich [ __ ] knock dude
laying on his back he i think he was
drunk because he was having a good time
and looked on his face like he wasn't
sleepy
and some guy's saying over like hey man
do you need help he's like where am i
and he goes you're out front of a subway
sandwich no you're out front of the
subway
and he was i'm not on the subway i'm
like this guy's [ __ ] hanging out dude
it was like 2 p.m on a tuesday i gave a
uh this homeless dude was out front like
a stephen star restaurant
he was like walking he's like man let me
get down and i was like here take
i had like easy 75 to 100 worth of
leftovers it was very expensive
and i was like yeah i can part ways with
this i you know i was at that perfect
level drunk i'm like i'm doing something
good yeah yeah
yeah i handed it to him he opens it up
looks at it looks at me and goes
he threw this [ __ ] thing 40 feet in
the air backwards and i laughed so
[ __ ] hard
just what a power move yeah like he
wanted to see how good it looked and
then he's like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you you yuppy piece of [ __ ]
guess what nobody's eating tonight
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what am i going to do with this ah harry
covey [ __ ] you
duck garage get the [ __ ] out of here
we were on temple's campus one time and
we ordered
the capacity [ __ ] your mother yeah he's
got an expensive palette
are you still homeless and wants to bury
your friend no sorbet what the [ __ ] am i
i'm sorry kevin it's all right i'm not
getting back into that
um all right uh let's see got a couple
of more here and we'll wrap her up
uh this is from jordan um have you ever
refrigerated a starbucks cold drink for
the next day
yes really refrigerated a starbucks
coffee you come in with three quarters
because it's probably
your second or third of the day it's got
ice in it you're like this is still good
for the morning but the ice
the ice doesn't stay hear me out i've
done this before this is [ __ ] white
this guy's bonkos hold on i just want to
say this is a fantastic question home
run it is a great question
um shout out carl shut up paul jordan um
hear me hear me out the water is
displaced
by the coffee you know those coca-cola
candies the
the gummy bear coca-cola yeah it looks
like that kind of it
the water's at the top the water's at
the top and you can siphon it with the
straw
so i i i concentrated the [ __ ] is wrong
get that water right there i thought you
just mix it up a little bit and drink it
nah it's way too diluted because i want
to put more ice in
i don't know do you spit it out or drink
it the water
what the [ __ ] dude that's nuts yeah or i
mean
that's dirtbag [ __ ] you're siphoning i
think it's actually classy old one
leaving it in classrooms to go get a
[ __ ] starbucks of course
but hold on there's nothing wrong listen
i'm not [ __ ] joey siphons over here
i don't know what the [ __ ] yeah i don't
know what he's talking about
but that is a great thing when you put
it in there and it's cold there might
still be a little bit of ice in there
what's better than having a start your
day coffee that doesn't mean much to you
to get to the one that that matters
you know what if it's a [ __ ] body
it's new york there's a starbucks every
30 feet what are we doing go get a fresh
eat how do you [ __ ] with starbucks no
more
it's cause you're drinking half empty
whatever you find in the streets and
you're taking it off i know where'd you
get that russian coffee you have that
yeah this is from moa from where it's a
small boutique
oh my god got his hair done there
you still cut your hair right yeah you
do yes sir
every two weeks i mean that's knots
no it's like working on your own ferrari
because you got a good head of hair you
could really [ __ ] that down
oh man it's not [ __ ] touching it's
the ant touch this is where you go
really it's chick trying to [ __ ]
yeah she's gonna start asking me for
money that's what i'm dreading did you
make this cake yourself kev
yeah hold on before you two get caught
up in the semantics of this that the
other thing
yes of course kevin the classy thing is
to get one but doing that move
when like tommy said if it's your third
or fourth of the day and you don't
finish it
why waste it throw it in there it's
great the next day
i've known people that if they're on
their way home they get a coffee
they say they get a nice coffee they get
an iced coffee then they get a nice
coffee with no ice
they put that in the fridge that's a
flat that's a pro
this right here is my third i'm not
going to drink at all if i was around
the corner from my home
i put it right in there right in the
fridge the hot stuff you'll find
once it comes to room temperature
because that's where bacteria is yeah
yeah and then i'll just add ice to it
in the morning and then it's iced coffee
that's iced coffee that i don't hate
the siphoning water out yeah that's
[ __ ] i just remember doing that a few
times because the water differentiation
was so high i was like i can get rid of
this
i shouldn't have bought it no it's
[ __ ]
bananas crazy well now i bet you
somebody does it
so i'm sure they'll write in yeah this
guy will try it this guy
who has a specific question clearly does
it tell him to try it and tell him to
respond to you guys
and then you text me because i'll never
listen to the show
so we're roommates i wake up i walk into
this i'm late
we're roommates i'm out the [ __ ]
window you can have my [ __ ]
but i walk into the kitchen you're
oh yeah yeah that's yeah i'd be
concerned yeah you're right yeah
i'd wait i'd wait till no one's home in
the bathroom
no one's looking you can't shake it up
it has to be right out of the source
that's bananas i love it all right let's
see here
this is from dixon butts i don't think
that's his government name
have you ever bought something from a
vending machine that you didn't want but
you bought it because you were gonna get
a
possibility of a twofer like you saw
that it was double stacked or one
hanging and you were gonna get the bonus
i don't think i've ever that's a great
question going out of my way to do that
i don't think i would remember if i did
yeah it seems like something up your
alley but i was kind of deferring this
one to you
yeah i'll i'll shut up i'm pretty
specific when it comes to the vending
machines
and i'll take everything the only thing
i is
don't screw me um
yeah dude that usually happens when it
was like a pack of lorna dunes cookies
or some are like the lifesavers or
something i ain't [ __ ] with that
now you buying hard lifestyle lifesavers
is this the 90s are you saying recently
you bought lifesavers out of a [ __ ]
vending machine
i've bought lifesavers out of a vending
machine within the last five years
wow yeah wow yeah you don't like a
little hard candy instead of getting
minced you get a thing of them
oh wait just wait i was thinking the
mints you're doing pure rags
oh my god i know they're still [ __ ]
what are we in the depression why are
the [ __ ] doing that that's crazy
that's like skittles star bar and you're
going [ __ ] rags like
sometimes i like a lifesaver what do you
want the last time i had a hard
lifesaver was was in a stocking
for christmas sounds like a good year
that was your big gift dad got his bonus
of tears
i can't believe i got a half a pack of
lifesavers
you just jam that thing full of like
dollar candy and it's like oh dude man
mom and dad are doing good yeah yeah you
know what it's like russell stovers and
[ __ ]
shitty thin mints you're like holy [ __ ]
i didn't get the santa stuff yet
that's the best year ever good i
remember one or two years they
they like i don't know it was my
stepmother somebody i remember opening
like individually wrapped small
like say they got your batteries for the
remote whatever bingo they would
individually wrap one year they must
have time on their hands or something
each battery battery no no but in like
whatever was in the stocking was wrapped
which was like
i felt yeah i've never i loved it i was
like this is great
yeah yeah yeah just to keep your dumb
ass occupied thinking you got more
[ __ ] yeah yeah but yeah but it worked
i'm talking about it now [ __ ] 25
years later
one of the things that was up to 92. one
of the things was the remote control
i'm not gonna need that that's for the
hat that's for the family that's how you
know your dad's all [ __ ] up
everything just wraps up something he
really needs i thought you'd have fun
just
putting the batteries in yeah yeah i
mean i feel like it's a gun dude i never
i never remember my dad not being hung
over [ __ ] christmas he would come
down like a half hour 45 minutes after
my mom she's
really sitting there with her with her
coffee waiting on big steve to get down
the steps like and did you have to wait
to open
your mouth you don't have to be
screaming we get it you like it
stop screaming it's like a fun guy nah
he was great once it wasn't wear off
pajamas and boots on
i heard a pair of timbo's and a flannel
set
hey don't you work boots just loosen up
a little bit there's some quiche in the
kitchen
we weren't allowed to walk downstairs
until they were downstairs in position
and that was brutal jesus yeah waiting
for my dad to get out of the out of the
can
so i could check out the gi joe dropping
off a heater and a cigarette
i want to see what the new recruits look
like
all right let's do uh let's do one more
here this was big
big big in my family this was from alex
uh have you ever used a can of frozen
juice concentrate yes of course which i
mean was the nine that's
all i did yeah yeah that's all i knew
what juice was that was our lemonade
yeah yeah yeah
we did orange juice that way tropicana
orange
we made iced tea with the frozen lemony
my mother would make the tea lipton tea
bags
hot boil uh-huh and then she would take
the like a tom collins or arnold palmer
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah then she
would take the frozen and do like a half
and half half and half
and eight that's pretty [ __ ] classy
i'll pay you that that's why i got
hooked on t course swiss
swiss farms tea cooler [ __ ] delicious
what's swiss in my early 20s all i drank
was tequila
he's twisted and tequila tequila and tea
cooler
what's tea cool it's iced tea and
lemonade it's on a palm
okay you mix it with tequila dude who
calls it tea cooler though swiss farms
oh oh i gotcha i know exactly what
you're talking about the plastic
yeah the gal the gallon [ __ ] farm
yeah yeah yeah yeah vodka or that in
tequila
damn yeah for five six years that was my
[ __ ]
and look how you turned out that's great
tom oh come on
scaring heroin addicts out of the alley
all right let's wrap it up gang what a
fantastic episode tommy thank you so
much for coming in and sitting with us i
love you uh anything you want the folks
out there to know you got coming up just
uh no there's a couple fun things i
can't really talk about but uh tommy j
pope
on twitter and instagram that's it very
nice kippy what do you got for him guys
uh at
comedy social media also follows the
follow the are you garbage pages at our
garbage on twitter
instagram guys the cards the live shows
in raleigh
and nashville uh good night good night
and zany's nice
and uh yeah patreon.com we're looking
forward to it come out and see a show